samedi on a pu découvrir un candidat un
peu trop sûr de lui qui a énervé viany
regard des réseaux j'en connais aucune
fiche chanter uniquement mes textes dans
le port d'amsterdam
yannick on sa voix est puissante mais je
trouve qu'il ya quelque chose d'un peu
lisse je m'ennuie un petit peu c'est un
duo mais c'est un combat pour s'entendre
là-dessus
une danse
quand on est crashé dans les eaux
is here et d'un accordéon
il s'attarde le goût pour mieux
s'entendre
jusqu'à ce que la cour
et on va souffrir si haut par un moment
tu la regardes et franchement elle n'a
pas l'écraser c'est pas possible quoi
mais des talents comme silvio j'en ai
pas vu beaucoup je garde
c'était chaud ça c'était chaud ce que je
me calme les mots c'était très serré
c'est d'échoppés c'est insupportable
enfin d'autres attitudes c'est basique
ça comprend pas qu'il l'ait pas dégagé
france me l'ont pas possible alors il si
vous avez touche le ballon il chante mal
il est pas un at il raison de regarder
alors ça vous n'allez pas me dire que
c'est parce que florent pagny ouais
c'est pour le buzz et le gard parce
qu'ils savent que ça va faire encore des
clashs et tout ça deux raisons le nom la
prophétie c'est vrai nom alors on à moi
j'aimerais revenir quand même aussi sur
vianney ce week end dernier était aussi
l'invité que cet avis et le chanteur a
été interrogé sur un possible arrêt de
sa carrière et j'ai été étonné de la
réponse de mon pote dany regardez vous
pourriez vraiment arrêter maintenant
d'être sur le devant de la scène
ah oui oui oui je sais que ça s'arrêtera
même définitivement
bientôt je le ressens quoi je sais que
quand le jour où j'aurai des enfants je
n'aurais pas envie de tenir ce rythme là
de d'une vie de chanteur donc je lui
faudra juste que je trouve des
équilibres pour continuer à être heureux
en faisant des choses que j'aime mais en
ayant assez de temps et de présence pour
pour les gens que j'aime voilà j'aurai
tellement calme il est tellement lucide
vraiment intelligent il est tellement
apaisé il essayait un électron libre
aujourd'hui je trouve
il dit toujours le contraire de ce qu on
attend que un artiste 10 en fait nous
faut qu'ils les hormones et du coup il
est intemporel et je trouve qu'il est
incroyable il s'affiche ni s'enfuit
alors le problème avec vanessa qui
risque de coûter un petit peu cher à tf1
en fauteuil sana shows on l'a vu danser
debout sur son fauteuil regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ils m'ont mis en boîte en boîte toutes
les boîtes sont fermées alors il est
content de venir faire de celle en
discothèque
[Rires]
[Musique]
oui alors j'adore j'adore the box mais
j'ai trouvé que samedi avait un truc un
peu irrégulier c'est qu'il ya des coachs
externe qui vient alors il va brûler les
vols sont formidables mais pour
l'instant ils savent pas grand chose ou
s'il faut des messages écrits oui ben
lewis et de seconde chance sinon je
alizés vie j'ai appelé viennent et voir
s'il va vraiment arrêter sa carrière et
me les candidats travaillent à peine
plus que nikos alors y compris et puis
pour ce crime là y avait encore y avait
encore le rappeur de vie dans ce prime
là ils ont dû l'effacer complètement
ménard et ses couteaux l'année pour tf1
et selon mes infos il est allé assez
loin dans la compétition de ma vie donc
ça va être très très compliqué pour eux
de l'effacer complètement en postant
s'ils vont complètement l'effacer
terminé donc je vis c'est terminé ben
non c'est lui en tout cas c'est lui qui
l'a confié sur les réseaux sociaux on à
demi mot est la dure on va certainement
encore me voir longtemps
c'est via la messagerie puisqu'elle a
dit ils vont certainement me flouté un
dernier pardon c'est moi frérot
tu as peur tu vas pas arrêté là ta
carrière on a besoin de toi la barre est
aussi tu t'en vas pas des chansons ont
via les eaux pures des cas on ira faire
du pas de l'ensemble je t'embrasse mon
chéri non mais c'est important lui dire
ça parce que m'vila fait une battle avec
une jeune fille qui avait beaucoup de
talent on est donc forte à vouloir le
handicap et la jeune fille dont qui
savent pas encore comment ils vont la
réintégrer au procès mais elle est bien
antérieure à l'époque qu'ils avaient
coupé mesnel il avait fait disparaître
je vais elle chantait individuellement
dont on garde l audace avait alors
déplacé des battles n'est apparemment
effectivement comme il a été loin ça va
être très compliqué et moi ce que je
comprends pas c'est qu'il laisse
perdurer le malaise il aurait dû la
faire une grande nico sera différent
plaçant courageux pour une fois directe
dire voilà ce qui s'est passé voilà
comment on gère la touloise émission on
va dire que bien servi viti jeu